Winter is coming. All of us were asked to wear a jacket when we left, otherwise we would get cold
Of course, the common response today is "Do not be ridiculous", _ Translation Team (Arasns) _
Being cold can not cause you to get cold, or you can! Who wins the battle of these beliefs?
The link between cold weather and disease is already there. Between (5-20)% of Americans
They get colds almost every year late fall and winter. Not to mention that it is called "colds".
But there are some important things to consider. First, the most important thing:
Is that the colds and flu caused by viruses, if none of them in your surroundings, you will not get them
No matter how cold you feel. It's that simple
If it is related to low temperatures? First: People tend to stay at home for a while
Often longer during the winter, which in turn makes them in contact with more people.
More people, means greater exposure to the spread of pathogens. Above all,
Humidity plays a role in the spread of certain viruses. In low humidity in winter
Not only does the virus spread quickly, but the mucus also dries up in your nose.
In other cases, mucus acts as a protective shield against pathogens.
The loss of vitamin D that we get from the sun can negatively affect our immune system.
Both stay longer at home and the fact that winter has shorter days
Together, they make a great impact on your health.
If your parents have proved wrong, right? Not so fast!
While some previous studies have shown that it has nothing to do with temperatures, recent evidence has suggested otherwise.
In a study made _ and as test materials _from the feet of some people in icy water, they found that they were in fact more vulnerable
To develop symptoms of colds in the following days, from those who did not undergo the test
The hypothesis resulting from these results is that the cold temperature causes blood vessels to contract.
Which slows the arrival of white blood cells to the virus,
Thus inhibiting the immune response. Levels of cortisol - which hinder the functioning of the immune system_
It increases with heat induced by intensity. Further, studies have been conducted on both mice,
Human respiratory tract cells that the immune response to the cold virus is based on heat.
Infected and warm cells are more likely to succumb to programmed cell death
To reduce the spread of sepsis.
Finally, studies of the virus itself revealed unique secrets. In winter temperature
The outer virus layer, or casing, becomes more powerful and plays a shield role.
This virus can spread from person to person more easily. In warm temperatures
This layer is closer to a gel that is not strong enough to protect the virus from external factors.
As a result, their deployment capacity is weak.
So, maybe your parents were not completely wrong after all this. A happy settlement can be reached out
Dressed in warm clothes will ensure the passage of winter without causing you any harm.
Are you new to AsapSIENCE? We've set up some playlists to make watching your videos easier
The first combines our favorite and most popular videos and the second includes
Every video for AsapSCIENCE on the cascade, why not? Also make sure you follow us
On Facebook, Twitter, Google Plus, Templer, Entragam, Fine and the rest of social networking sites you know.
Links are in the description below.
As usual, ask your questions and participate in the channel for more weekly science videos!